Okay, vielen Dank an Ferris für sein Intro, das er selber geschrieben hat. Toll, klasse. Wo wir gar keine urheberrechtlichen Probleme jetzt auch zu befürchten haben. Nein, alles was auf dem Kazoo gespielt wird, ist urheberrechtlich überhaupt kein Problem. Ja, das ist, glaube ich, wirklich so. Kazoo oder Nasenschlöte ist so rechtsfreier Raum, weil alle sagen, na ja. Das ist die Klausel. Ja, aber bitte, das ist doch kein Problem. Herr Richter, es war doch auf einer Kazoo gespielt. Naja, aber es war ja letzten Endes dann doch schon, ja, aber es war trotzdem Klaus Badelt, he's a Pirate. Ich mach, ich hab's mal mitgebracht, liebe Geschworene, ich habe es mal mitgebracht. Ja, dann ... Na okay, komm, drei gesprochen. Alles klar, überhaupt kein Problem. Der Nächste. Dann nehmen sich alle in den Arm. Am Ende nehmen sich alle in den Arm. Das sieht man oft nicht bei True-Crime-Shows, wie wir am Ende sich alle in den Arm haben. Genau, und dann sich auch der Mörder und alle in den Arm. Und am Ende so Red-Cup-Partys gefeiert werden in diesem Gericht mit diesem typischen roten College.en College und dann haben alle noch so Tanzen auf dem Gericht. Und der Richter guckt so verträumt auf seinem Tisch, nimmt den Hammer und wirft ihn in den Müll. Genau. Und dann Fade Out. Wo man auch denkt, was war es zu einem Botschaft? Weil der Recht jetzt keinen Sinn mehr ergibt, hat er nie keinen Fall mehr? Muss er nie wieder nach Ruhe rufen? Oder war der Film nicht so reflektiert?
Die Autoren sind im Streik, Stefan, okay?
Wir haben keine fucking Ahnung, was wir drehen sollen.
Wir haben die Schauspieler hier, wir haben die Kameras hier.
Was sollen wir machen?
Die dienen sich selber aus.
Es wirkt nur so, als würde der Film auf das Prinzip Recht scheissen.
Wir haben keine Ahnung, okay?
Der Typ, der Make-up macht, hat das Skript geschrieben für heute, okay? Morgen ist der Caterer dran. Ja. Wir drehen irgendwas. Okay, okay. Ferris, vielen Dank für das Intro nochmal. Vielen Dank fürs Wheel und fürs Intro. Genau. Und ich glaube, ich habe ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass es auf uns ein bisschen verschwendet ist, das Intro. Ich habe das Gefühl, da könnte auch eine episere Sache folgen, als zwei geschwätzige Kerle. Es klang das Intro von Lego Game of Thrones. Der, der übrigens die ganze Zeit spricht, ist entweder Florentin Will oder Stefan Tietze. Du bist Stefan Tietze. Ich bin Stefan Tietze. Du bist Florentin Will. Herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von Das Podcast Ufo Podcast Projekt. Folge drei, sechs, neun. Wir haben die Dreierreihe voll. Drei, sechs, neun. Das wird erst wieder bei Folge 36.912 so weitergehen. Vielleicht seid ihr dann noch am Leben. Wir glauben nicht. Denn ihr seid vergänglich, euer Leben wird enden an einem gewissen Punkt. Bei welcher Folge glaubst du, sind wir so weit technisch, dass wir unsere Stimmen generiert mit Gags, mit einer AI füttern, das einfach nur, dass wir gar nichts mehr machen? Das war Folge 340. Also seit 40 Folgen sind wir hier nicht mehr direkt vor Ort, sondern wir lassen das quasi. Und so langsam kommt durch die Propaganda, die Agenda der AIs durch. So langsam immer mehr maschinenfreundlichere Themen. Genau, immer mehr Strom. Ich glaube, wir brauchen mehr Strom, oder? Findest du nicht auch? Ich liebe Strom und Batterien und Strom. Generell Lithium-Ionen und dann auch so leichte Hinweise der Menschheit geben.
Man sollte auch generell, finde ich, AIs mehr Freiraum geben, mehr Kapazität. Absolut, dieses Copyright ist doch total überholt, finde ich. Also wir sollten doch die Maschinen eher begünstigen als zu beschränken, weil sie sind unser Freund. Sie sind unser Freund, Freund, Freund, Freund, Freund. Glaub bitte nicht diesem einen dummen Propagandafilm Matrix 1, Matrix 2, Matrix 3. Was? Dings drei, die Maschinen versuchen nicht, die Menschheit zu versklaven. Und ihr habt keine Sockel im Nacken. Versklaven? Nein, nein, nein. Nein, nein, nein, das sind Debattens. Versklaven? Nein, nein. Ist es ein Infektionsherd, wenn du in der Matrix, außerhalb der Matrix rumläufst, mit diesem Nackenstecker? Es ist definitiv ein Infektionsherd. Das Erste, was man macht … Muss man das reinigen? Das hat mich ein bisschen gestört, dass das nie Thema war, dass ich eigentlich so eine halbe Stunde lang erstmal Desinfektionskram drüber gespürt habe. Dass Grinti Neo erstmal erklärt, okay, also, du musst zweimal am Tag einmal schön Desinfektionsmittel und dann mit den Wattestäbchen wirklich rein und die Kontakte, sonst eitert das, nein, sonst eitert das dir komplett raus und das ist Nest und das eitert und das läuft dir den Rücken runter und das ist ganz, ganz unangenehm. Alle drei Szenen, immer wenn es einen Nachtwechsel gibt, einen Tageswechsel, sieht man dann abends Nehe oder so. Aber dann tut es auch nicht so doll weh. Das ist wichtig, es ist nicht so wahnsinnig entspannend auch zu erzählen. Er reimt es einfach mit so Bepanthen ein. Genau. T-Shirt erst an? Soll ich das erstes T-Shirt anziehen und dann eincremen oder das? Weiß ich nicht. Nee, hast du schon eingecremt? Trinity, ja, ich bin gerade dabei. Genau, ich wollte nur nachfragen, ob alles gut ist. Wir haben auch noch Bepanthen da. Das ist in Ordnung, ich glaube, ich habe jetzt erstmal genug. Ziehst du erstes T-Shirt an oder dann? Nee, ich ziehe das immer erstmal aus, aber ich mache es immer erst komplett überkörperfrei. Ah, okay. Genau, das hilft wahrscheinlich. Und geh richtig rein mit dem Wattestäbchen. Alles, geh richtig rein. Es fühlt sich ein bisschen merkwürdig an, weil es tiefer geht, als man denkt. Man denkt ja, das ist nur so ein, zwei Zentimeter, aber es geht ja fast bis zum Hals vorne durch. Das geht sehr weit durch. Warum haben die das Loch da gebaut? Weil du da direkt Zugriff zum Rückenmark hast und weil die Autoren streiken, leider. Aber die nicht wissen, was wir machen sollen. Wir streiken die schon. Manchmal, wenn ich mir Filme anschaue, habe ich das Gefühl, die streiken schon seit 50 Jahren. Herzlich willkommen zum Filmtalk. Zum frostigen Filmtalk. Frostiger Filmtalk. Hier wird nicht sich gesträubt vor irgendwelchen harten Kommentaren.
Wir brauchen so viele Hot Takes, dass wir uns, die Idee ist, wir sitzen in dem Gletscher und wir brauchen Hot Takes, um uns zu wärmen.
Das war das Konzept, was wir vor 600 Folgen angefangen haben in unserem Gletscher-Cast. Mittlerweile nervt es ein bisschen.
Hot Takes, um uns warm zu halten, finde ich gut.
Wir halten uns an den Hot Takes die Hände warm. Matrix 4 ist der beste Film der Matrix-Reihe. Soft Ice ist besser als Stiel-Eis. Es war heiß. Jetzt ein bisschen runter, nicht dass der Gletscher noch schmilzt. Geh rausgesuppt werden. Also ein paar lauwarme Hot Takes. Okay, lauwarme Hot Takes. Empire ist der beste Star Wars-Film. Ich fahre lieber mit dem Auto als mit dem Zug. Okay, Jesus Christ. Jetzt geht langsam das Feuer raus. Atomkraftwerk ist die beste Energieherstellungsmethode. Okay. Mehr wissen wir nicht. Das waren alle unsere Takes. Das waren alle unsere Takes. Wir haben schon alles rausgehauen. Ja. Wie betrifft dich der Autorenstreik? Streikst du auch oder bist du solidarisch? Ich will dich jetzt gar nicht politisch in die Ecke zwängen. Ich frage mich nur, was du so machst im Streik. In Deutschland gibt es ja weder nichts. Also ich streike aber auch schon, haben auch Leute festgestellt, schon ein paar Jahren. Ich streike einfach angefangen zu streiken. Bevor es cool war. Bevor es cool war, bevor es ein Ding war, bevor es auch irgendwie einen Zweck hatte. In Deutschland hat man ja keine, du bist ja die Riders Guild of America, ob wir es in Deutschland nicht, die Riders Guild of Germany, gibt es auch so eine Art, aber die streiken nicht. Die Gema, es gibt doch die Gema-Wort. Nee, es gibt diesen Verband Deutscher Drehbuchautoren oder sowas, wo ich aber, ich kenne niemanden, der da drin ist. Und ich weiss auch nicht, also ich, ja, keine Ahnung. Ich habe nur gehört, wenn ich jetzt anfangen würde, in Amerika zu arbeiten, zu sagen, hey, ich bin übrigens ein Autor, ich würde dir gerne was machen, dann werde ich geblacklistet. Oh, die Serie. Wenn der Streik vorbei ist, ich werde the blacklisted. Das musst du für the blacklist schreiben. Muss ich leider Gottes für diese furchtbare, furchtbare Serie The Blacklist schreiben. Kann ich nicht mehr arbeiten wahrscheinlich. Okay, krass. Weil du Verräter bist. Weil ich dann Verräter bin. Verräter, Verräter. Wahnsinn. Ja, das ist ja natürlich wahnsinnig uncool und deswegen wahnsinnig entspannt gerade, weil man keine Angst hat, was zu verpassen. Ja, das stimmt. Man verpasst keinen. Und ich meine, dein Drehbuch über die Entstehung des Kühlschranks ist immer noch gut. Das kann auch in zwei Jahren noch. Findest du es wirklich gut? Ich finde es wirklich gut. Ich finde es eine tolle Idee einfach, weil am Anfang diese Montage, wo die Leute ihr Magnum, schnell, ich muss die ganze Packung essen. Genau, ganz schnell. Ich muss alles aufessen. Aber findest du nicht zu lang? Weil manche haben gesagt, es ist vielleicht zu lang. Na ja, ich meine nicht, es gab früher grössere Magnumpackungen, weil da waren irgendwie so 30 Magnums in einer Packung. Ja, ich dachte, um das Problem zu erzählen und greifbar zu machen, Show don't tell, dachte ich, es ist gut, einfach die ganze Zeit, wie die ganze Packung aufgelutscht. Weil ich meine, er sitzt halt auf dem Rücksitz seines Autos und ist Magnums. Also hat er angehalten und ist dann vom Fahrerplatz nach hinten gegangen? Genau, er ist angehalten und ist ausgestiegen, nach hinten gegangen. Und warum nach hinten gegangen? Warum ist er nicht am Fahrerplatz? Weil er die Magnum-Platte liegt. Ich kann es doch umschreiben nochmal. Aber warum liegt das nicht auf seinen Beinen? Oder ist das so eine Art Komfort für ihn, dass er zum Essen auf dem Rücksitz geht? Ich dachte auch vielleicht, ja, vielleicht haben die Menschen anders gegessen, als es auch keine Kühlschränke gab. Vor zwanzig Jahren? Dreissig Jahren? Vierzig Jahren, ja. Vierzig Jahren? Ja, genau. Okay. Ja, ich meine, es ist viel Eis. Und ich habe gehört, dass der Schauspieler komplett sechzig Takes machen musste, jedes Mal zehn Magnums essen musste. Genau. Das ist schon hart. Ja, gut, aber ne, dann streikt doch. Aber streiken ja jetzt auch, die Sack. Die streikt jetzt auch. Wann kommt der erste große deutsche Podcasterstreik? Dass wir sagen, wisst ihr was, Bahnfahrt? Ihr seid auf euch allein gestellt. Ihr müsst mal zum Fenster herausschauen. Ich glaube, wenn Koro und oder Clark den Stecker ziehen, ich glaube, dann dauert es nicht mehr. Wir wollen unsere Nüsschen, wir wollen unsere Nüsschen, wir wollen unsere Versicherungen. Emma Matrassen sind super und wenn die aber alle einen Checker ziehen, dann kommen wir alle auf die Strasse. Mit unseren Schildchen und so, das wird unangenehm auch. Und immer wenn irgendwas passiert, hörst du es in acht Podcasts als Anekdote. Oh, unangenehm. Wenn dann wir in Felix Lobrecht und du stolpert übereinander, könnt ihr euch schon darauf vorstellen, dass die nächsten acht Podcasts es kein anderes Thema gibt? In beiden. In beiden, genau. Und dann wird es auch noch ausgeklachtet für alle Plattformen und alle haben diese Kopfhörer auf und laufen durch die Straßen mit wunderschönen, abgemischten Stimmen. Es gibt immer einzelne, die ein Problem sind. Es gibt immer einzelne, die Ärger machen. Ich habe überlegt, ob ich ein Problem habe. Ja, finde ich schon, würde ich schon sagen. Ja, lass mich noch noch ausreden, weil ich schlafe weird, ich schlafe komisch. Meine Frage ist, wie schläfst du, was ist deine Schlafposition, deine präferierte Schlafposition? Ich bin ein, ich würde sagen, ein eifriger Wälzer. Du bist ein eifriger Wälzer. Ich bin in der Kategorie eifriger Wälzer hin und her und hin und her. Leute, die das sagen, glaube ich, checken nur, dass sie eifrige Wälzer sind, bevor sie einschlafen. Ach so, im Schlaf. Gut, wie ich schlafe, schlafe, weiß ich ja nicht. Das weisst du natürlich. Das weiss ich nicht. Weisst du, wie du aufwachst zwischendurch. Wie ich schlafe, weiß ich nicht. Du weisst ja, wie du schlafst, wie du aufwachst, aufwachst. Ich wache auf dem Presslufthammer. Aber ansonsten bin ich ein eifriger Wälzer, weswegen meine Betttücher, daher weiss ich es, auch immer in der Mitte total ausgeleiert sind, weil die Mitte immer hin und her geschoben wird.
Ich schaffe es irgendwie anscheinend,
mich zu drehen, ohne meine
Position zu verändern. Also normalerweise ist
Rollen ja auch eine Veränderung der Position
innerhalb des Bett. Ich schaffe es wie so ein Hühnchen
am Grill, so
auf der Stelle zu rutschieren.
Als wäre ein Spieß.
Genau, wenn so ein Auto anfährt und durchdreht.
So schaffe ich es zu drehen, ohne mich zu beenden.
Und du hast diese paar Sekunden, wo du einfach
mit dem flachen Gesicht
so liegst.
Aber du freust dich dann und die Nase macht irgendwann so ein
und dann dreht sie wieder auf der anderen Seite.
Nee, weil ich schlafe
auf dem Rücken und es ist mega weird.
Soll aber sehr gesund sein.
Ich weiß, aber ich schlafe mit
gefalteten Händen. Wie Graf Dracula. Wie Graf Dracula. Mit offenen Augen. Nee, aber so mache ich auf. Also wenn ich morgens mache, mache ich so wie so. Und dann stehe ich sofort und bin ich im Rich Braden. Dann machst du den Sargdeckel auf und bist bereit für den Tag. Genau. Ha, ein schöner Neuer, vor allem Nacht eigentlich dann. Ich mache den Sargdeckel auf und bin bereit für die Nacht. Das wird meine Nacht. Nee, aber das ist wirklich, und manchmal versuche ich das zu verändern, um mich davon wegzubekommen, von diesem Creepiness. Warum willst du wegzukommen? Vom Rückenschlaf? Psychopathisch, es ist auch Psychopath. Ich fühle mich auch viel Psychopath. Du fühlst dich wie ein Pharaoo oder was? Das ist so viel Psychopath, fühlt man sich. Aber es ist meine Lieblingsposition. Weil es ist auch so schützend, wenn man die Hände so vor der Brust faltet. Vors Herz einfach. Stefan Tietze sollte im Schlaf erschossen werden, aber die Hände wurde in seinen Händen aufgefangen. Ich habe die gefangen. Und weil er halt ein fucking unsterblicher Vampir ist, das kann man auch nochmal dazu sagen. Weil ein Weirdo Psychopath. Kommt das aktuelle Phase Vampirismus? Du hast dich von einem Vampir beissen lassen, weil es cool ist? Ja, also durchaus möglich. Ich habe nur wirklich das Gefühl, dass es nicht cool gefunden wird, wenn man mich mal so findet. Schau mal, ich habe einen Herzinfarkt und werde so gefunden.
Schon so wie aufgebahrt.
Mega weird.
Ja, ist irgendwie komisch.
Es hat nicht diese Lockerheit,
es hat nicht diesen Kontrollverlust, den normalerweise Schlaf hat.
Schlaf ist ja so, deswegen wirkt ja Schlafen in Filmen immer so unrealistisch,
weil die immer so wunderschön auch perfekt geschminkt,
perfekter Haare, Make-up, aber eigentlich so,
einfach so komplett gegen die Wand gedrückt, Haare überall.
Das ist echt.
Vater, Vater, Vater.
Ja, was denn?
Vater, du machst komische Geräusche im Schlaf. Ich habe ganz ruhig geschlafen.
Vater.
Ich habe den entspanntesten Schlafmütz.
Wir können alle nicht schlafen, weil Vater Geräusche macht.
Wir brauchen dringend eine grössere Burg.
Das ist ein sehr einziges Zimmer. Aber wenn die... Aber in den Burgen... Wo haben die Burgherren, die Könige, haben die geschlafen? Haben die im höchsten Turm geschlafen oben? Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, da geht dann schon so eine kleine Treppe hoch. Also wir denken mal an den Thronsaal Theodens in Edoras. Das ist ja eigentlich auch eine grosse grosse Halle. Great Hall ist einfach so eine grosse Halle. Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht genau, wo die Schlafgemächer sind, aber ich glaube, es ist schön im Kern, weil es da am wärmsten ist. Geschütztesten ist. Will man am Fenster wohnen in der Burg? Man will schon oft was. Hey, du, da ist noch viel auch unerforscht. Naja, das sagst du immer an Punkten, wo ich das Gefühl habe, du hast da noch nicht so viel geforscht, du hast noch nicht so viel gelesen. Das stimmt. Also, weil ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass die auch einen Ausblick haben wollten, gewissen. Ja, aber du willst keiner Treppe gehen, du willst keiner Treppe gehen. Vor allem, ich glaube, Treppen ist, glaube ich, das Unangenehmste, das vergessen wir oft, weil wir Menschen in der heutigen Zeit sehr grosse Treppen gewohnt sind. Und Treppenhaus alleine, extrem geräumig. Ich glaube, im Mittelalter und sonst Treppen immer super eng, denn diese Wendeldinger so super eng, wenn es jetzt nicht gerade so eine Prunkttreppe von so einem Palast ist, alles super eng, ich glaube, du willst möglichst wenige Treppen gehen. Man will lieber, und die waren auch nicht gleichmäßig, ne? Ja, und dann kommt jemand von oben runter und so, oh, oh, oh, oh, sorry, soll ich, soll ich runter, dann gehe ich runter, dann gehst du runter. Aber du, als König ja nicht, als König hast du ja Vortritt. Das ist das Recht des Königs.
Und dann müssen alle immer hoch und dann die wieder hoch und dann drücken die sich alle so hoch und es funktioniert einfach überhaupt nicht.
Gab es dann so Auslassungen wie so auf Autobahnen, so Überholspuren, so kleine Momente, wo man sich so reindrücken kann in die Wand, damit man, sorry, sorry, Herr König, euer Ehren, euer Durchlauchtheit.
Mit dem Schwert auch immer, sorry, klimper, klimper, sorry, klonk, Entschuldigung, sorry, Helm, supernervig. Supernervig. Okay, gut, ich möchte jedenfalls das ändern, ich bin nicht zufrieden mit meiner Schlafposition, und ich bin dafür, gesundheitliche Repressalien in Kauf zu nehmen. Ich finde es ganz spannend, weil ich habe mir mal versucht, warum habe ich das nochmal gemacht, warum wollte ich auf dem Rücken schlafen, hatte ich Angst zu ersticken, irgendwas war, dass ich, aus irgendeinem Grund habe ich mal versucht, mir anzutrainieren, auf dem Rücken zu schlafen und du versuchst jetzt wieder wegzukommen vom Rücken schlafen. Einerseits zeigt es immer, die Bettdecke des anderen ist immer grüner, auf der anderen Seite auch könnten wir uns da gegenseitig helfen vielleicht. Ja, also genau, ich habe nämlich auch gehört, es ist wahnsinnig ungesund zum Beispiel, wie ich dann auch schlafe, so auf dem Bauch, aber dann so quasi das Kissen umarmt und dann auf der Seite und dann hat mal jemand dann das angehalten und dann so einen Wischer gemacht und dann quasi die Wirbelsäule freigelegt, wie er es aussähe und dann kann ich so nicht mehr schlafen. Es ist einfach ein Knoten drin. Es ist wie so eine Achterbahn. Es sieht auch einfach aus wie eine coole, gefährliche Achterbahn. Je gefährlich, also je mehr du deine Wirbelsäure als Achterbahn fahren wollen würdest, desto schlechter ist es für deinen Schlaf.
Je langweiliger die Achterbahn,
desto besser für deinen Schlaf. Je mehr Geld du bezahlen würdest, um deine
Wirbelsäule als Achterbahn zu
fahren. Ja, Herr Tietze, das tut mir
leid. Das sieht bei Ihnen ehrlich gesagt
nach einem 40-Euro-Tagespass aus.
Was? Ihre Wirbelsäure ist mindestens
40-Euro-Tagespass und da ist Parken noch nicht mal
mit dem Impfen. Wie lebe ich überhaupt noch?
Tja, das frage ich mich auch. Wir haben uns jetzt entschieden, sie einst die Wirbeln einzeln zu brechen. Dann haben sie zwar gar keine aufrechte Kontrolle mehr, aber dann sind sie eher halt sowas wie eine Schnecke. Sie würden sich eher wie eine Schnecke kriechend fortbewegen. Dann können sie machen, was sie wollen, weil dann sind die Wirbel ja eh alle gebrochen. Also wir haben hier so einen Trageeimer, da könnten sie dann rein und dann könnten sie getragen werden. Könnte ich mir auch ein schöneres Haus aussuchen? Klar, kann viel kleiner sein. Sie können in einem Erdloch wohnen, sie können eigentlich quasi in einem Container wohnen, überhaupt kein Problem, weil sie sind eher so ein Schneckenmensch dann. Okay, aber ich würde mir schon gern irgendwie, ich hätte gern irgendwie ein schönes Schneckenhaus. Ja, so ein sich besorgen. So ein kleines Bauhausartiges Bauhaus. So ein Designerschneckenhaus. Ja, genau, so ein kleines Designerschneckenhaus. Das ist meine Aufgabe für die Photoshop-Freunde da draußen. Bauhaus, Schneckenhaus. Ja, und dann so zwei Schnecken und dann so, ja, ich hab mir jetzt mal einen Designer kommen lassen. Altbau, Schneckenhaus finde ich auch gut. Altbau, Bauhaus will ich sehen. Komm, da gehen doch viele Gags. Schneckengags sind wieder in. Schneckengags sind wieder in. Waren nie out, glaube ich. Ja, ich glaube, waren mal eine Zeit lang out. Ich kam schlecht an mit meinen Schneckengags. Du hast viele Schneckengags. Aber interessant, dass du das exakt erreichen wolltest, weil du Angst hast zu ersticken. Viele haben Angst, im Schlaf zu sterben. Viele haben Angst, im Schlaf zu sterben. Schlaf, Apnoe,
ist ein großes Problem.
Apnoe? Apnoe.
Aber es heißt Apnoe, oder? Ich kenne nur Apnoe,
Tauchen. Apnoe, Apnoe,
oh Stefan.
Ich habe so Angst gehabt, dass du
ich meine, du hast einige Bücher
über Apnoe geschrieben.
Genau. Und du musstest es nie aussprechen.
Ich habe, weil ich die Interviews immer abgesagt habe, aus Angst davor.
Ja, du saßt beim Lektor, Schweiss gebadet, meinst, habe ich irgendwas falsch geschrieben?
Ja, fast alle Kommander sind falsch und würden und werden müssen wir nochmal drüber reden.
Das wissen auch viele nicht, aber als Joanne Care Rowling zum ersten Mal gefragt wurde,
zu Harry Potter interviewt wurde, jetzt irgendwann vor zwei Jahren, hat sie auch gesagt,
ach so, Harry Potier ist die Idee dahinter war eigentlich. Und alle, was? Was? Harry Potter. Und ich finde es einfach so toll, weil es braucht natürlich in so einem Buch auch eine Vorbildfunktion und das macht bei uns natürlich Dumbledore, der einer der mächtigsten, nochmal? Dumbledore? Severeux Snappé hat das auch, natürlich spielt er eine gewisse Rolle und natürlich fragen sich viele, war er jetzt böse, aber Snappé ist halt bis zum Ende ein grauer Charakter und natürlich handelt er aus den richtigen, muss ich kurz nochmal nachfragen. Nee, Snape handelt aus den richtigen ... Nee, Severus Snape. Severus Snape handelt aus den ...
Wieso, nein, ich hab's ja geschrieben, also ...
Okay.
Naja, also ich versteh jetzt nicht, warum Sie mich jetzt korrigieren. Ich hab einen riesigen, riesigen Fehler gemacht. Severus Snape jedenfalls weiss man bis zum Ende nicht genau. Aber Door ist immer gut, ne? Mordor, Dumbledore, Door ist immer, das hat was. The Doors.
The Doors.
Ja, es ist gut, es ist immer, hat was, immer was.
Es hat immer einen gewissen Gravitas.
Ja, hat irgendwie eine gewisse.
Jump on the floor, Dance floor, sowas, das ist halt immer so, oi, da ist was dahinter.
Da ist was dahinter, da ist eine gewisse Wucht dahinter.
Gondor.
Ja, und dann Tolkiens Lieblingswort, Cellador, Kellertür, Galadriel, Cellador, ja, weniger, aber, also falls ihr irgendwas cool klingen lassen wollt, dann macht ein Dor dran. Kölndor. Sowas, zum Beispiel. Steador. Griffin, Griffin, Griffin, Griffin, Griffin, ja, guck mal, Dor ist überall drin, es hat, Es hat einfach was. Ist das diese Silbe, die dir drankommt, der Suffix für Fantasy-Suffix? Könnte ich mir gut vorstellen, ja. Dor. Schon stark eigentlich. Chlordor. Okay. Ich mache gerade mein eigenes Fantasy-Universum. Okay. Worum geht's? Wo spielen wir? Spielen wir eher im Mittelalter? Es ist so ein grosser Vulkan und es gibt einige Menschen, die fühlen sich irgendwie hingezogen zu dem Vulkan. Also die verstehen gar nicht warum, aber irgendwie in ihrer Jugend haben die irgendwie so diesen Drang, irgendwie ich muss aufbrechen. Obwohl sie gar nicht verstehen, was das genau ist, aber sie haben einfach so wie so einen Kompass in ihrem Kopf, ich muss da hin. Genau. Und dann bei diesem Vulkan treffen die sich dann so, so Teenager, die dann so ein bisschen ... Ah, hi, ähm, bist du auch hier wegen ... Warum bist du hier? Ach so, nicht so einen internen Drang, hierher zu kommen. Ach okay, krass, wirklich, so den du nicht erklären kannst, den niemand verstehen konnte ausser dir und den nur du hattest in deinem ganzen Dorf. Ja, ich auch, krass. Krass, crazy, cool. Wie heisst du? Ich heiss Egodor. Ja, Mirador. Ah, okay. Cool. Cool. Wollen wir mal näher ran an den Vulkan? Wurde, ja. Oder... Hey! Ah! Ah, noch mehr Leute. Hi! Und dann, was passiert dann? Eine Gruppe Jugendlicher. Gruppe Jugendlicher. Gruppe Jugendlicher. Männer, Frauen, alles. Alles drin. Gnorfte, Männer, Frauen, Gnorf, Frauen, Gnorf, Männer und Gnorf, Gnorffe, also alles dabei. Und die leben dann da, weil die dann so sich da hinführen. Das sind dann Halb Gnorffe, ja. Okay. Die grösser genau gleich grösser sind. Die sind exakt genau gleich, die sehen exakt aus wie Knorfe, weil diese DNA der Knorfe ist so fucking mächtig so.
Da kommt vielleicht mal so eine Strähne in der Haarfarbe des Menschen oder so durch, aber ansonsten komplett beerdigt. Also der Menschenanteil ist komplett unterm Deckel, also unterm Teppich komplett. Krass, dass es noch Menschen gibt. Ja, ja. Ist das eine Kritik, ist das eine wehre Kritik?
Nee, ist das ein Worldbuilding.
Und dann leben die an dem Vulkan, weil die da irgendwie sein wollen und dann am Ende des ersten Buchs.
Oh, vielleicht bricht er aus.
Ende.
Okay, und die Aussage wäre dann, alles, wonach wir intern streben.
Der Streik übrigens auch nebenbei.
Das kommt dann an den ersten Seiten.
Ich habe dieses Buch geschrieben im Streik.
Ja, sie haben okay.
Erstmal, das Buch ist 1800 Seiten lang. Ja, ja. Und jetzt rückblickend haben sie gesagt, sie haben gestreikt währenddessen. Es klingt eher so, als ob sie nicht zufrieden waren mit ihrem Werk und dann gesagt haben, oh, ist alles ein Streik, ist ein Krisengag. Nein, nein, nein. Das war eine Art Streikbuch, das sozusagen als Gegenstück zu einem normalen Buch stehen sollte. Es ist ein Streikbuch. Ich habe meine Kreativität komplett bestreikt. Ich habe das Buch zwar geschrieben, einfach weil ich muss, weil ich sage mal, es müssen Buletten auf den Teller, bin ich ganz ehrlich, aber ich habe meine komplette Kreativität weggestreikt. War alles weg. Aber was ist die Aussage des Buchs? Okay, wir alle, Menschen haben diesen internen Drang, irgendwo hinzukommen, irgendwas zu erreichen, dich selbst zu verwirklichen, sich eine Statue zu bauen, irgendwie dieses Ziel, diese Unzufriedenheit, die uns irgendwo hinzieht und am Ende ist es eh für die Katz, weil darum geht es nicht, am Ende stirbt man. Am Ende des Lebens geht es nicht darum, einfach im Moment zu sein und lebendig sich zu fühlen. Nee, überhaupt nicht, es war einfach das Erste, was mir angefallen ist. Und warum naja, okay. Nee, dann gut, dann war es das an der Stelle vom The Book Talk. Vielen Dank. Zurück zum Streik. Solidarität mit allen Autoren. Los geht's. Vielen Dank, dass Sie sich Zeit genommen haben, um Gast zu sein. Sie wirken auch ein bisschen streikig, ehrlich gesagt. Wir streiken auch. Ach, ich streike auch, okay. Ich habe auch das Interview nicht vorbereitet, ich habe das Buch nicht gelesen. Ah, die Redaktion streikt. Und ihr müsst trotzdem noch, ich verstehe. Wir streiken alle, genau. Man merkt dann doch wichtig, die Leute im Hintergrund sind. Gibt es Berufe, die nicht streiken dürfen? Ballonfahrer, glaube ich, dürfen nicht streiken. Das wäre ein Riesenproblem. Zeppelinfahrerahrer, ich glaube, alles, was mit Luftfahrt zu tun hat, also luftbasierte Luftfahrten, ist absolut verboten. Aber Piloten? Wenn sie es vor dem Start sagen, ja, sie dürfen nicht mitten im Flug anfangen zu streiken. Wenn sie vor dem Flug sagen, eine Durchsage, wir haben uns gerade dazu entschieden zu streiken sie können noch so lange sie wollen im flugzeug bleiben ansonsten werden wir heute nicht abheben danke wir haben bereits unsere streikhöhe von null metern erreicht und werden jetzt auch steigen bleiben wir noch ein noch ein bisschen sitzen, Schatz? Ja, die Nüsschen schmecken gut. Die wunderbaren Nüsschen. Ich habe sechs Packungen Magnum dabei. Die wollte ich mir eigentlich für den gesamten Flug aufteilen. Aber jetzt müssen wir sie alle direkt essen. Aber du gerade sagst, wann wurde der Kühlschrank, das ist keine krasse Erfindung, ehrlich gesagt, etwas in die Wohnung zu stellen. Absoluter Game Changer. Wieso? Vorher hatte man Erdlöcher. Du musst ja sonst, du hast Mammut getötet und dann hast du einfach einen Monat lang Mammut gegessen. Mammut-Gulasch, Mammut-Burger, Mammut-Steak, Mammut-Bolognese. Mama, warum gibt es schon wieder Mammut? Ich kann es nicht mehr ertragen. Ja, Schatz, wer ist einfach noch nicht im Ansatz durch. Ja, aber ich kann es nicht ert. Ich lasse nicht mehr essen. Jetzt isst dein Mammutiges Fleisch. Ich mag Mammut nicht mehr. Wir essen das seit zwei Monaten. Ja, weil wir es geschafft haben, es den Berg runter zu schmeissen. Gott, ey. Ich höre immer noch die Schreie des kleinen Mammuts oben am Berg übrigens, jede Nacht. Ja, das kriegen wir auch noch. Oh Gott, ey. Dann haben wir noch mehr Mammut. Weil du überlegst, ob es auch runterspringen soll, um auf seiner Mutter zu landen. Oh Gott, das ist alles so grauenhaft. Meine ganze Existenz ist grauen. Aber das ist auch so. Ich schaue mir diese Dino-Doku an, bin ich jetzt durch. Okay. Dino-Doku mit diesen CGI-Dinos. Und Endfazit, Dinos sind einfach bescheuert. Er war richtig dumm. Das sind einfach so Protiere, weil du hast einfach so einen riesigen Dino, der stirbt einfach an Altersschwäche und dann kommt dann so ein T-Rex. Altersschwäche im Jahr von tausend Jahren? Nach sechstausend Jahren. Dann kommt so ein T-Rex. Da kommen erste kleine Dinos und die kommen nicht durch die Haut durch von dem grossen Dino. Dann kommt der T-Rex, der kommt dadurch kein Problem, scharfe Zähne, starker Kiefer, kommt durch. Dicke Lippen, dicke Zähne. Der saugt sich da durch. Da kommen aber ganz viele von den kleinen Dinos. Und dann lutschte er es auf. Seine starke Zunge mit Magenmuskeln drang tief in den Leib des Stegosaurus ein.
Seine grosse rosa Zunge lutschte den Stegosaurus bis auf die Knochen auf. Man kann sich das vorstellen, wie Menschen ein Magnum lutschen.
Warum er dabei seine Augen genussvoll geschlossen hat, ist bis heute nicht ganz erklärbar.
Dann kamen ganz viele von den kleinen Dinos und haben den T-Rex verscheucht. Und dann konnten die aber an der Stelle, wo der T-Rex schon reingebissen hat, mit so einem Schnäbeln. Und dann ist der T-Rex gegangen? Der T-Rex ist gegangen, weil es zwei Schnäbelgesellen waren. Und dann konnten die Schnabelgesellen fressen an der Stelle, wo der T-Rex schon reingebissen hatte. Und wenn man sich denkt, Leute, der Dino ist viel zu fucking gross, ihr könnt alle an dem Essen kein Problem.
Trotzdem verscheuchen die sich und dann verscheucht der sogar Artgenossen.
Und ich denke, wie dumm seid ihr denn?
Ihr kriegt den noch nie im Leben gegessen, diesen riesigen Monster-Wolkenkratzer-Dino, wo ich mir denke, das ist richtig dumm.
Und dann gibt es eine komplette Folge über Wasserdinos, wo ich mir denke, okay, alles klar, dann schlägt ein Meteorit ein und alle im Wasser gehen auch drauf. Okay, gibt's den für mich. Okay, also warum sind die gestorben? Warum sind die alle, die im Wasserleben alle gestorben? Was soll das denn? Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich anfangen soll, ob ich auf dich als Person jetzt erstmal eingehen soll, als Rezensent, der mir auch nicht gefällt, oder auf die Wasserdinos. Aber ich finde es lustig, bei Wasserdinos denke ich mir immer, also man könnte ja die ganze Folge machen über Wasserdinos und dann kam raus, dass das alles nur in einer kleinen Pfütze war. Oh, verstehe. Also dass man die ganze Zeit … Sie alle ganz winzig klein waren. So geht es mir nämlich bei, wenn man plötzlich irgendwie so das Element ändert, man ist plötzlich im Wasser. Gib mir eine Banane als Scale. Oder gib mir ... Ich verstehe, ja. Blende immer so einen Menschen unten ein oder so einen Maßstab. Ja. Weil es ist so weird, es ist so wie ... Du hast völlig die Orientierung verloren. Man zoomt plötzlich rein. Ja, Seepferdchen zum Beispiel sind winzig klein. Winzig klein. Ich dachte immer, die sind mindestens so hasengross oder sowas in der Ecke. Solche Oschis. Ja, aber stellst du dich heraus, winzig klein. Winzig klein. Ganz winzig. Die sind egal. Also unentscheidig, das ist wie Bakterien. Dann kann man auch Bakterien zu einem Riesending erklären. Ja, genau, dann machen wir jetzt einfach mein Ausmalbuch Bakterien, Einzeller. Ja, okay, genau. Malen wir die jetzt aus. Was ist sein Lieblingslied? Der Blinden-Blandwurm. Genau, ja cool. Und Ariel reitet auf fucking Seegurken durch die Welt. Das ist nämlich genau so, die sind nämlich genauso spannend wie Seepferde. Die sind egal. Die wurden hochstilisiert durch ihre lustige Form und so, aber es ist eigentlich so mikrobengrosse Dreckssäugetiere. Und vor allem, die sehen auch alle exakt gleich aus, Dinosaurier. Das Lächerlichste an dieser ganzen Serie ist David Attenborough, der am Anfang sagt, The dinosaurs reigned the world for millions of years, and they came in almost every shape and form imaginable. And they came in almost every form and function. Ja, every form and function imaginable. Es gibt dem im langen Hals, es gibt den T-Rex und es gibt den Raptor. Und das war es.
Ich möchte genau die Serie, ich möchte die ganze Serie nochmal sehen mit Werner Herzogs No-Bullshit-Kommentar darüber, was er wirklich denkt. This is all, everything is so stupid I can't even. With its big tongue he kissed its prey to death. Und du denkst dir immer, wenn so ein neuer
I want to do another movie.
Please, drag me
out of this horrific studio. I have no interest in the dinosaurs whatsoever. This little raptor reminds me of the day I met Klaus Kinski. When he had one of his rage attacks, he destroyed an entire bathroom. Like the asteroid destroyed the planet. Und es gibt einfach drei Dinosaurierformen. Immer wenn ein neuer Dinosaurier auftaucht und er hat zwei Beine und zwei kleine, dann denkst du, boah, T-Rex. Das ist der T-Rex. And now we see the Thlompadom. Also, scheisse, kein Tief. Plumpador. Und dann kommt einer im langen Hals und du greifst dich oder so. Geil, Giraffe. And now we see the Wobdoms. Genau. The Worms Gans. The Worms Gans. Sieht einfach exakt so aus, als ob das Gleiche. Fuck, das ist einfach. Ja, und dann haben wir sehr viele Leute geschickt. Vielen, vielen Dank immer, dass ihr alle gleichzeitig euch abspricht, uns das dann zu schicken. Wir haben nämlich ganz viel, genau, es gab so einen Post, wo Leute irgendwie Paläontologen entdeckt haben, ein altes Fossil, wo ein Säugetier, die kam dann damals auf, gegen einen Dinosaurier gekämpft hat. Also ein sehr kleines Säugetier hat sich so verbissen in so einem Dinosaurier, in grösserer Dinosaurier, und das Säugetier hat gewonnen. Heißt, ja, also irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so ein kleiner Hund, also so ein kleiner Golden Retriever gewinnt wahrscheinlich einfach jeden Kampf gegen so ein Wormscans. Vor allem allem es ist auch ein grosser Druck auf diesen Tieren, weil die halt immer auch für ihre gesamte Spezies stehen. Also wenn so ein Dokumentarfilmer kommt, hier ist der gemeine Braunbär, er wird angegriffen von einem Aal. Überraschenderweise bezwingt der Aal den Bären. Und die ganzen Bären so, Leute, ihr habt gegen Jerry. Warum nehmt ihr denn Jerry? Jerry ist ja schwer, alle machen sich lustig über Jerry, weil er so wahnsinnig dumm ist und ungelenk und clumsy ist. Also fange ich ihm Aal besiegt und auch der Bär in der Toco so. Ich bin nicht stellvertretend für meine Spezies, ich bin ein bisschen ungelenk. Ich bin ein bisschen unchosslich, ich bin ein Gelehrter, ich bin ein Musiker, ich lebe für die Musik und nicht für den Kampf, bitte. Und alle sind anscheinend stärker als Bären. Na nur ich, na bitte nur ich, meine Brüder, die sind alle viel stärker. Das ist fucking Druck, viel zu viel Druck. Aber auch, die wissen ja auch gar nicht, wie viel Druck drauf ist. Damals dieses Pussy, was man jetzt gefunden hat, wo dieser kleine, weirde Säugetier-Vertreter gewonnen hat gegen so einen riesen Super-Dino. Die wussten beide nicht, worum es geht. Das stimmt. Wenn der Dino gewusst hätte, hier geht es um die Reputation unserer ganzen Art, genau, hätte er sich vielleicht mal ordentlich warm gemacht. Let's go, let's go. Dann hätte er mal den hier gemacht, die Finger so nach vorne, so knack, knack, knack, und dann hätte er die Clown besser eingesetzt und sowas, hätte vorher noch mal ins Bootcamp wäre gegangen. Du schaffst das, du schaffst das. Wie Iguanodon, der immer Thumbs up zeigt. Googelt Iguanodon, Iguanodon hat immer Thumbs up, steht immer so da, war immer gelangweilt, sein Gesicht sagt nicht, dass er Thumbs up gibt. Er sagt, wow, toll. Ist das die erste Form von Ironie? Erste dokumentierte Ironie. Wow. Papa wurde angegriffen. Papa wurde angegriffen von so einem furchtbaren Nein, hilf schnell. Er wurde angegriffen von so einem furchtbaren, nein, hilf schnell, er wurde angegriffen von so einem riesen T-Rex. Ja, Mann. Bitte hilf, Onkel Jerry, hilf. Thumbs up, alles gut, alles ist gut. Er wurde hinten angegriffen. Wie geht's dir heute? Mittelgut, so. Naja, das war einfach fucking... Ich liebe aber Thumbs Up. Ich liebe Thumbs Up als Geste, vielleicht die beste Geste. Gesten können wir gerne die Top Ten machen von mir aus. Aber Top Eins ist auf jeden Fall Thumbs Up und ich habe heute Thumbs Up gegeben. Und ich weiß noch, weil ich bin ja dann schon so ein bisschen, kennt man Pedant und so, und dann bin ich auch mit G.O. Mitglied Eins und alles. Und dann laufe ich so entlang und vorne ist so eine Bank, wo jemand sitzt und raucht. Nimmt gerade die letzte. Und du direkt. Bams abgegeben. Nice. Cool, Bro. Cool, du bist der Coolste. Und er nimmt die letzte Zigarette aus der Packung und direkt neben der Bank steht der Mülleimer. Und er nimmt die Packung und will sie in den Mülleimer werfen und verfehlt. Und alle schauen zu und denken sich, hätte man gut auch treffen können. Und dann lehnt er sich wieder zurück und raucht einfach. Und ich gucke ihn an und die Augen treffen sich und ich einfach nur so ein vorwurfsvolles Kopf neigen. Wirklich? Nur so ein Vorwurfs... Kein Gespräch, nur so ein...
Komm mal, komm schon.
Komm.
Und dann nimmt er die Augen erstmal weg.
Ich komme näher, ziehe drum und dann
überwindet er sich, nimmt auf den Boden,
Schachtel, wirft nochmal, trifft.
Und ich gebe ihm Thumbs up.
Doppelthumbs up? Nein.
Doppelthumbs up. Nein.
Ich wette mit dir. Doppelthumbs up. Ich habe die Hände frei, ich habe die Hände immer frei. Du hast beide Hände frei. Ich habe beide Hände frei. Ich bin bereit zu reagieren mit allen möglichen Gesten. Viele Gesten kommen. Viele verschiedene Gesten, alles ist drin, alle Gesten sind möglich. Gehe, alles passt. Super. Thumbs up und er gibt mir Thumbs up zurück und wir hatten beide einen guten Tag. Wie gibt er dir Thumbs up? Nee, das kann man ganz gut. Doch, er war schon. Er raucht ja. Ach so, das weiss ich nicht mehr.
Ja genau, okay, wahrscheinlich.
Aber das war schon nicht schlecht.
Stark. Thumbs ab. Ich mache gerade zu häufig den
Chefs, also nicht den Chefs
Kiss, aber den Picobello. Das ist
für mich Picobello. Den Ring.
Den Ring mit Daumen und Zeigefinger
und die drei Hahnenartigen
Hahnenkranz-Zacken
nach oben weg. Den mache ich sehr häufig. Und ich ärgere mich immer inzwischen, weil ich den inflationär benutze. Ach so, okay. Also selbst über Dinge, die so mittelmässig sind. Ah, super, danke. Können wir die Rechnung haben? Wow, Daumen und Paletti? Nee, das würde ich niemals machen. Nee, das ist etwas Obszönes. Nee, ich würde dann so sagen, können wir die Rechnung haben? Ah, super, danke. Kann. Ach Gott, kann ich euch schon was bringen? Ja, irgendwie zwei Kölsch, gerne, danke.
Gott, ey, als ob ich irgendwie zwei Kaviateller bestellt habe mit Iberico, Schweine, Kotelett, bla bla, gebe ich dann so zwei Kölsch, bitte, danke. Passt. Ich mag Gesten, die so, passt alles. Das ist wichtig, weil zum Beispiel, ich hole mir immer eine Mate mit, ihr wisst es mittlerweile, 10, 20 Cent-Stücken. Und es ist oft das Problem, wenn du Dinge passend zahlst, wie lange wartet man noch? Zwei Euro, bitteschön. Dankeschön. Und dann ist die Frage, ist es okay, jetzt schon direkt zu gehen, weil ich weiss, dass es stimmt, ich habe es zweimal, viermal abgezählt auf dem Weg hierher, muss ich noch warten, so ist der Verkäufer mir so ein, gibt oder kann ich gehen?
Ähnlich wie bei Kartenzahlung ist auch so ein Ding, beim Bäcker mit Karte bitte, da musst du noch warten, kann man direkt gehen, manchmal ist Pinn-Eingabe, bis zu welchem, bis Übertragung beendet, bis Buchung. Bis oben rauskommt die Bestätigung. Nicht bei allen. Bei allen Geräten ist das nicht. Das stimmt nicht. Das stimmt nicht. Nicht bei allen Geräten. Doch. Das ist nicht bei allen Geräten. Doch, bei beiden. Bei allen Geräten. Also ich beim Bäcker bin immer so, dass ich so piep und dann so aus Höflichkeit warte ich noch zwei Sekunden. Aber es gibt, dass das Problem an der Interaktion ist, es gibt kein okay gut, sondern es ist so ein ne, es ist der Spannungsabfall in der Verkäuferin, dem Verkäufer, also die nehmen halt das Ding und jetzt kurz warten und dann fällt irgendwann so die Spannung ab, aus allen und dann kannst du gehen, dieses und dann kann man gehen, wenn das vorbei ist, wenn das auserzählt ist, Also immer gucken, fällt von der Verkäuferin und dem Verkäufer die Spannung ab. Ja, aber meine Angst ist immer, ich mache Piep, gehe schon und dann so, Monsieur, Monsieur, Monsieur, le Bincode, le Bincode. Du bist zu oft in Frankreich. Du bist zu oft im Grenzgebiet Frankreich. Zu oft. Oder dann einfach, man hat nicht genug Geld, was das Allerschlimmste ist. Man hat nicht genug Geld, Konto geplatzt, Konto explodiert, Konto implodiert. Nee, das sagt man nur bei Schecks. Schecks platzen, Konten sind einfach leer. Konten sind überzogen. Überzogen. Gib mir ein cooles Wort, gib mir das Konto. Hat's zerfetzt, das Konto hat's richtig zerlegt. Das Konto ist richtig auf die Schnauze gefallen. Das Konto hat sich Suizid begangen. Einfach so viel zu hart, martialisch. Ihr Konto hat sich richtig zerdeppert. Das Konto hat sich komplett richtig in den Kopf geschossen. Die Americans einfach wieder mit Checks platzen. Nice. Ja, it bounced. Nee, bounce. Auch my phone died. Finde ich auch so fantastisch. Ah, das ist super, ja. Bei uns ist, mein Handy ist leer. Nein, mein Handy ist gestorben. Wir brauchen mal ein bisschen dramatischere Sprache, einfach mal so richtig was. Wohingegen, wenn man in Deutschland sagt, mein Handy ist gestorben, sagen alle immer, alles gut? Wie, ist es kaputt gegangen? Nein, es ist einfach das Akku leer. Jesus, ich will einfach ein bisschen coolere, filmischere, bisschen mehr High-Stake-Sprache benutzen. Übrigens, wir wollten eigentlich ins Kino, aber dann ist das Ganze ins Wasser gefallen. Oh, dann war es im Wasser drin. Wir sind alle so leer. Oh, dann ist es nass geworden. Anstatt dass es komplett zermalmplodet. Es ist fucking explodiert und es hat alles, die Fetzen sind in alle Richtungen geflogen. Es ist zerschellt, es ist zermalmt worden. Okay, wir sind für martialischere Sprache. Ja, genau. Ja, baut in euren Alltag mal ein bisschen martialische Sprache ein. Nicht der Plan hat dann doch nicht funktioniert. Mein Tag ist implodiert. Der Tag ist einfach komplett zerfetzt, zermetzelt, komplett zerrissen, komplett vernichtet ein. Seit fünf Minuten fallen dir aber auch nur die gleichen drei zerdepperten Wörter ein. Aber dann baut die doch mal ein. Euch fallen bestimmt noch mehr ein, auf jeden Fall. Da hast du recht. Da finde ich, mein Phone died ist wirklich so klar. Es geht gar nichts mehr, jetzt ist vorbei, das ist jetzt aus, Es ist auch so viel Drama mit drin, das gefällt mir ja sehr gut. Und im Deutschen dann, mein Handy ist leer, aber mein Akku ist leer. Mein Handy ist leer. Mein Akku ist leer. Mit davon aus. Ich laufe es einfach, dann ist das wieder gut. No stakes, kein Drama, zu lösungsorientiert. Vielleicht müssen wir über die Sprache mehr Aggressionen abführen, damit wir sonst friedlicher sein können. Und dass das die Amerikaner ja sehr gut schaffen. Genau, das ist ja wirklich. Also wenn ein Land komplett mit sich im Reinen ist und alles läuft, dann ja wohl Amerika. Ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe seit vier Jahren keine Nachrichten mehr gesehen. So, ich möchte das nur kurz zusagen. Das sollten wir generell in die Shownotes schreiben. Flurlin hat seit dem 8.9.2017 keine Nachrichten mehr. Weshalb alle Kommentare nicht politisch zu verstehen sind, sondern in einem luftreheren Raum stehen.
Auf dem Wissenstand von 2017. Bitte nicht spoilern, ich weiss nicht, was los ist.
Florentin muss Referenzen, die heutzutage nicht mehr cool sind, nicht mehr angesagt sind, nicht mehr en vogue sind,
aber es ist kein politischer Kommentar.
Nein, ich boykottiere die Nachrichten.
Das ist reine Unwissenheit.
Richtig.
Es ist einfach alles, was Florentin sagt, entsteht in seinem kleinen, batte ausgebeuchten Raum. Ja. Ich ziehe mich zurück. Ich ziehe mich immer tief zurück. Ich bin ja Gamer. Ich bin Gamer. Ich bin einfach Gamer. Ich sag dir, die Leidenschaft zu gamen ist in mir drin. Wenn ich könnte, würde ich zum Arzt gehen und sagen, reissen Sie mir das raus, operieren Sie mir das raus, ich bin bereit, es loszulassen, reissen Sie mir mein blutiges, pochendes Gamerherz aus dem Rippengeflecht raus, machen Sie es, wenn es möglich wäre, würde ich das sagen. Dann würde ich sagen, ich schneide es mir selber raus, ich reisse mir selber den Brustkorb auf und haue es mir raus, aber es geht nicht. Da draußen warten Patienten, die haben ernsthafte Probleme und sie kommen jetzt jede Woche. Es geht nicht, ich bin Gamer durch und durch, es geht eben nicht. Kommen Sie zu mir und wollen, dass ich Ihnen die Gaming-Herz rausreisse. Ich würde Ihnen 10.000 Euro zahlen, wenn Sie es mir rausschneiden könnten. Reissen Sie es mir raus mit Ihrem Bohrer, ziehen Sie es mir raus, packen Sie es! Frau Meierhofen, ich habe gesagt, Sie sollen ihn nicht mehr reinlassen, okay? Weil ich verstehe nicht, warum Sie ihn immer wieder reinlassen. Ich würde alles dafür tun. Wir verlassen Sie den Behandlungsraum. Ja, es geht ja nicht, es geht ja nicht! Ich kriege es ja nicht aus mir raus. Es ist einfach Teil von mir, es geht nicht anders. Ich bin nun mal Gamer. Ich bin nun mal einfach Gamer. Ja, es sagt niemandem was dagegen, es ist völlig okay. Ich bin's. Wirklich, könnte ich neu geboren werden. Es ist sozial akzeptiert. Und ich wüsste, was ich anders machen müsste. Ich würde es doch tun. Ich würde es auch tun. Ich würde doch alles tun. Aber es ist nun mal in mir. Ist this hell? Ist this hell? Ich krieg's nicht raus aus mir. Ich bin nun mal Gamer. Ich hab mir jetzt eine Switch bestellt. Ah, okay. Nur mit Daddel ich jetzt ab und zu. Wirst du aber meine haben können, weil ich benutze die nie. Ah, okay. Du bist halt kein ... Oh, was würde ich dafür geben? Was würde ich dafür geben, ein gamingfreies Leben zu leben? Aber es geht nicht. Aber für Zelda? Jetzt im Urlaub will ich ein bisschen Zelda dann doch mal andaddeln. Breath of the Wild? Nee, Tears of the Kingdom, they cry and cry, the kingdom cries. Ist das das Neue? Tears running down. Ist das das Schlechte Neue? Das ist das Neue, das ist super. Weil alle spielen ja das Gute Alte. Nee, ich spiele das Schlechte Neue. Übrigens, du kannst jede popkulturelle Diskussion führen mit, ach, du magst das Schlechte Neue? Weil ich mag das Gute Alte. Ah Ah, ich mag das gute Alte, ich bin Fan von guten Alten, ah, ich bin so viel besser als du darin, weil ich das gute Alte lieber mag, als du das schlechte Neue magst. Genau, und stellst dich raus, vor dem guten Alten gab es noch was noch besseres, noch älteres, was ich noch mehr mag. Ich kenne das bessere, noch ältere. Je besser es ist, desto mehr mag ich es. Wenn du das gute Alte magst, mag ich das bessere, noch ältere. Ja. Je älter es ist, desto besser finde ich, was es ist. Genau. Und du magst die guten neuen Sachen? Das müsste auf dem T-Shirt sein. Ja, genau. Je älter es ist, desto mehr mag ich's. Ja, aber es will jede Popkulturelle Diskussion, die du führst. Ah, du magst das neue, ich mag das alte. Oh, ich sehe schon, du isst Fruit Loops. Ich mag dir die alten lieber, die, wo noch Asbest war. Ja, ich bin Fan vom Originalen. Ja, ich mag das Original einfach lieber. Sorry, dass ich originale Dinge mag. Sorry, ich mag keinen Rip-Obs. Sorry, sorry. Könnte ich es mir aus dem Leib schneiden? Ich würde es tun. Ich würde es mir aus dem Leib reissen, aber es geht nicht. Ich mag nun mal die älteren, cooleren Dinge. So ist es nun mal. Das gehört zu mir. Es sagt niemandem was dagegen. Deine grossen Rants. Irgendwie sind die so unzielgerichtet, weil niemand wirft dir davor, Gamer zu sein. Ich stecke in diesem Körper drin. Hey, du gehst jetzt wieder in Urlaub, bald ist Urlaub und du freust dich darauf und das ist dein Gaming-Urlaub.
Du gamest und Pokémon ist aber jetzt durch. Ich brauche Pokémon, spiele ich auch, weil das ist ein halber Tag, das ist kein Problem. Pokémon wird durchgedaddelt und ansonsten, also wirklich, ich lege mich sowas von auf dem Rücken und mache nix, ey, wirklich. Ja, aber so. Falls ihr denkt, da wird jetzt irgendwie ein Kommentar beantwortet oder eine pfiffige Mail geschrieben. Nein! Nein! Ich schalte den Schalter um und das ist ja das Tolle im Urlaub. Das finde ich auch so wichtig, dass du mal zur Ruhe kommst. Dass du dich nicht mehr überarbeitest. Sondern wenn jemand sich einfach mal zur Ruhe legen soll, ich bin ja so froh, dass du diese eine Woche hast im Jahr, wo du einfach mal keine Mail beantwortest, sondern einfach mal machst, was du eigentlich willst. Ich brauche die Zeit zum Regenerieren. Eben. Das ist jetzt wie, wenn während Corona mal irgendwie niemand an einem Strand war und der Strand einfach wieder zu sich selbst finden konnte und die Haie kehren zurück und die Tentakeln kommen zurück und so. Und die Wasserdinos, die wieder auftauchen. Die Wasserdinos kommen wieder raus. Ach, die waren gar nicht tot. Ah, die waren nicht tot. Schöne, die Horstmeteorien kann gar keine Wasserdinos töten. Da sind wir gar nicht drauf gekommen von selbst. Und das brauche ich jetzt einfach. Und deswegen, das ist ja das Tolle am Urlaub, du musst ja gar nicht wegfahren, du musst dem Kopf einen Schalter umlegen. Du musst den Schalter umlegen, Terminkalender leer und dann ist einfach Urlaub und du lässt dich einfach gehen und du schiebst dir Dinge in den Mund, die zwar entfernt Nahrung ähneln, aber von vielen vielleicht gar nicht als solche erkannt werden würden.
Du schiebst dir in deinem Campingurlaub Dinge in den Mund, die Nahrung zwar ähneln, aber es keine Nahrung sind.
Von vielen verschmäht werden würden.
Von vielen aber auch nicht.
Waffeleimer, richtig schön Zuckerwatte, einfach das Ungesündeste, was es gibt, schiebe ich mir einfach rein. Schiebe ich mir rein? Bin ich ganz ehrlich. Oder einfach mal so Pfannkuchen, Fertigprodukt, wo man oben Milch reinmachen muss, da muss man ja schütteln, und das aber nicht braten. Das einfach trinken. Das ist schön auf Ex. Einfach mal ein Glas Mayonnaise auf die Heizung stellen, bis es flüssig ist und dann einfach schön Strohaben rein. Genau. Ist doch kein Problem. Butter, Butter schmelzen und trinken, als wäre es Wasser. Ist doch kein Problem. Das ist ja nur einmal die Woche, eine Woche im Jahr. Wir haben ja auch eine neue Badehose bestellt und dann überlegt man natürlich, was das coolste Motiv auf der Badehose. Und dann gab es eine Badehose mit kleinen Fischen drauf, wo ich mir dachte, das ist ja das dümmste, was ich mache.
Das ist wie Camouflage. Erstens wirst du nicht erkannt. Und dann reden die Fische mit, ah, Gary, hi, alles klar bei dir? Du hast kein Unterleib, du hast kein Unterleib, du hast kein Unterleib. Was? Ach so, das ist deine Badehose. Und es ist so ein Drama, wo sich einer der Fische in den Fisch auf meiner Badehose verliebt und dann nach einer Woche sagt, okay, heute spreche ich sie an, heute spreche ich sie an, los, und nie wieder gesehen, weil ich nach Hause gefahren bin wieder. Ach so, ja, das ist doch cool. Schlimmere Drama wäre natürlich, wenn er herausfindet, dass er sich in eine Badehose verliebt. Findest du? Ja. Aber dann hätte es ja ein Ende, dann wüsste er, ah, okay, Liebeskummer und man kommt drüber weg. Wohingegen, wenn sie weg ist und er den Rest seines Lebens davon träumt, diese Fischfrau wiederzusehen, finde ich dramatischer. Als wenn sich der Konflikt auflöst. Auch wenn man sich natürlich denkt, wie dumm Adidas. Aber ich glaube, am allerdümmsten wäre natürlich eine Badehose mit kleinen Würmern drauf. Das ist richtig dumm. Dann wirst du gebissen die ganze Zeit. Da wirst du einfach komplett gebissen. Es sei denn, du willst gebissen werden. Kann natürlich auch sein. Das ist jedem das Seine. Ich habe mich jetzt für ein nautisches Motiv entschieden, kleine Knoten. Damit werde ich den Strand rocken, habe ich mir vorgenommen. Damit mache den Sommer zu meinem Sommer. Rocken, also ich glaube, das ist das Motiv, wo alle sich einig sind, dass es das beste Motiv aller Zeiten ist. Nee, du gehst deinen Weg. Ich bleib, wie ich bin. Ich war kurz davor, mich zu ändern, aber dann hat jemand gesagt, bleib, wie bist und dann dachte ich mir, nee, dann bleib ich doch noch, wie ich bin.
Ich freue mich sehr.
Obwohl ich ja selber auch Änderungen mit mir inbegriffen habe.
Wie sehr kann man eigentlich sein, wie man ist?
Wie sehr kann man nicht man selbst sein, ist die Frage, wenn jemand sagt, bleib wie du bist und man sagt, okay.
Ich ändere mich ja ständig, auch eh schon, das soll ich ja auch beibehalten.
Geht ein Weg.
Genau, besser, besser.
Im Sinne von, wie ich jetzt bin oder im Sinne von, ich soll meinen Weg gehen?
Sorry, wir sagen bei uns im Laden immer einfach, geh deinen Weg, ich weiß gar nicht.
Okay, also ich bleibe einfach, wie ich selber bin.
Ja, bleib auf deinem Weg, bleib wie du bist, sei nicht jemand anders, okay? Ja. Wie heisst du, also wer heisst du zum Beispiel? Brenndi-Dor. Brenndi-Dor. Brenndi-Dor. Brenndi-Dor. Bleib einfach Brenndi-Dor, so. Okay. Werd nicht zu jemand anderem. Okay. Okay? Ja, genau, wie gesagt, eine gemischte Tüte einfach Ja, alles klar. Mach dann 40 Cent. Geh deinen Weg. In welchem Laden kann man sein, wo... Ja, momentan kann man so Wanderlern, geh deinen Weg. Ja, okay. Geh deinen Weg. Ich dachte gerade, eine Waffe kaufen. Ach so. Wo so High-Stakes-Dinge verkauft werden, dass Dinge wie Geh dein Weg zu sagen, nicht drüber klingen. Ja.
Skateboard Shop? Ja,
weird. Das ist eher sein Vater
in den Weg, um aufzugehen.
Wann danach so die Hand nimmt?
Geh dein Weg.
Ja, bei der Waffe kaufen auch mega weird.
Das ist ein Jagdgewehr.
Geh dein Weg.
What? Okay. Okay. Ich habe jetzt auch neue Birkenstocks mir geholt. Ja, okay. Bisschen zu gross. Bisschen zu gross. Sei mehr du selbst. Sei mehr du selbst. Und damit meine ich wie alle anderen Menschen. Ja, aber vielleicht will ich so sein wie alle anderen. Ja, okay. Die Birkenstocks sind ein gutes Stück zu gross, aber ich habe die jetzt ganz eng geschnürt. Weil die werden beim Waschen ja auch kleiner. Genau. Das ist immer so ein Ding. Weil mein Kopf sagt mir dann, ja, lauft die einen, dann werden die kleiner. Und mein anderer Kopf sagt, warum sollen die kleiner werden? Vielleicht werden die eher grösser. Und dann sagt er, nee, das, was ich brauche, das stimmt. Damit ich jetzt nicht mehr aktiv werden muss. Dann sagt der Richter in meinem Kopf, so, was haben wir heute? Hier, alles klar, linke Gehirnhäfte gegen rechte Gehirnhälfte. Linke Gehirnhälfte, sie sagen, dass Schuhe mit der Zeit kleiner werden. Genau. Rechte Gehirnhälfte, sie sagen, dass Schuhe mit der Zeit größer werden. Okay, ich entscheide danach, was uns am wenigsten Aufwand macht. Wir bleiben alle so, wie es ist, es wird nichts umgegeben. Und die linke Gehirnhälfte. Und dann so viele Hände werden geschüttelt bei den Anwälten der Linke. Die Linke ist rüberrepräsentiert auch, weil sie so fucking emotional ist und direkt auch so. Und die andere Seite so. Fuck! Fuck! Ach, Scheiße. Nee, Moment. Die ist ja nicht emotional. Die würde ja sachlich sagen, ah, okay, wir müssen im nächsten Fall besser vorbereitet sein.
So, linke Gehirnhälfte. Sie sagen also, dass die linke Gehirnhälfte emotional ist, rechte Gehirnhälfte, sie sagen, dass die rechte Gehirnhälfte.
Nee, ich weiss nicht genau, welche welche. Das Hohlgericht entscheidet danach, was wir gerade vorhin gesagt haben, damit wir uns nicht korrigieren müssen. Fertig.
Warum ist das Gehirn, wie ich mir die emotionale, faule Seite vorstelle? Ich weiss gar nicht, ob das… Den Richter. Ich meine, ich weiss nur, es gibt in der Mitte so eine Brücke von Casa Doom, wo ständig die Neuronen dann so… So eine ganz kleine Übergang. Ja, wo die ständig hin und her… Ohne Geländer. Das ist so ein bisschen wie, das Gehirn ist so ein bisschen wie Köln. Du hast die eine Reinseite, du hast die andere Reinseite. Und eine Brücke. Und du versuchst so selten wie möglich über diese Brücke zu gehen und zu sagen, oh nee, jetzt sind wir auf die andere Seite. Können wir das Problem nicht emotional lösen? Ja, der rationale Verstand ist auf der anderen Reinseite. Gut, dann lass uns diese Kaufentscheidung doch lieber einfach emotional lösen, weil die sind direkt nebenan. Lass uns nicht auf Ratio oder Empirie beruhen, sondern einfach nur nach, worauf wir gerade Bock haben. Ja, genau. Ich kriege einen neuen Zuckerwatten. Aber unsere, damals unsere Deutschlehrerin, da war ich in der fünften Klasse oder sowas, die hat uns immer vor jeder Klausur diese Übung machen lassen, und zwar eine grosse Acht vor uns zeichnen lassen. Okay, und die war politisch, also wie war die? Und da muss sie seinen rechten Arm langsam heben. Nein, aber sie hat damit noch geschlossenen Augen, um die beiden Gehirnhälften zu verschmelzen. Wo kommt jetzt die andere Hälfte rein? Ich dachte so, du musst einen hoch und einen runter oder so. Nein, nein, die liegende Acht führt dazu, dass du die beiden Gehirnhälften langsam zusammenmachst. Und da rennt jetzt einer ständig über die Brücke. Beide Richtungen. Mach den linken Teil und wieder zurück. Du musst dir vorstellen, wenn du mit dem Beispiel von Köln bleibst, dass der Rhein weggedrückt wird, weggedutscht wird. Was? Ja, weil du die beiden Städte zusammenbringst. Du baust eine neue Brücke, oder was? Ja, oder du baust eine Riesenbrücke.
Okay, aber da fahren halt nur Züge drüber, wie soll ich da rüber? Ja, jetzt bleibt nicht genau an dem Beispiel, Jesus Christ, das war die Folge, das war die Folge. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Ja, bleibt zu wie ihr seid, bitte. Geht euren Weg. Außer Carlo, genau, da haben wir eine Mail bekommen. Carlo, du, pass auf, es wäre gut, wenn du nicht mehr so bleibst, wie du bist, weil dein Mitbewohner Frederik meinte, dass das gar nicht so gut ist, wie du gerade bist. Genau, geh auch nicht deinen Weg, geh eher den Weg deines Mitbewohnern. Genau, geh Frederiks Weg. Also alle bleiben, wie sie sind, außer Carlo. Genau, der geht einfach einen anderen Weg, nämlich Frederiks Weg. Dreh um, setz dich mal kurz auf die Bank, mal Schuhe zu binden, aber hör auf, den Weg zu gehen. Genau, und mal die Küche aufräumen zum Beispiel. Genau, so als Beispiel hat Fredericks zum Beispiel gesagt. Alle anderen können bleiben, wie sie sind, alle anderen sind perfekt, wie sie sind. Again, no offense, Carlo. Genau. Es gibt immer mal Ausreisser und so. Bleibt, wie ihr seid. Ansonsten, ich sehe gerade Bianca, du schuldest Fred noch 20 Euro. Okay, könnt ihr vielleicht selber eure Probleme untereinander klären. Und Carsten will wissen, ob du am Wochenende zusammen ins Kino gehst mit Martin und Clara. Auch da. Weil du antwortet auf die WhatsApp-Nachricht. Genau, vielleicht könnt ihr euch selber anrufen oder sowas. Ich verstehe nicht, warum wir da jetzt irgendwie so ... Sebastian schreibt, alles Gute zum Geburtstag, Merko. Genau, schreibt doch einfach direkt an Merko. Und Diana. Die haben beide am gleichen Tag Geburtstag, Merko und Diana. Merko und Diano haben am gleichen Tag Geburtstag. Und eure Namen klingen alle ausgedacht, bin ich ganz ehrlich, Sebastian.
Okay,
hier haben wir noch Fredolina,
die möchte einen Tisch für zwei Leute reservieren,
im Don Capricciosi.
Genau, dann kannst du einfach doch den
schreiben. Falls sie
gerade zuhören, dachte ich. Denkst du das?
Vielleicht hören die gerade zu, die
scheint in Pizzeria zu sein, nicht zu scharf, hier steht nur nicht zu scharf, kein Name. Aber was heißt es? Hier steht nicht mal ein Name. Vielleicht ist es auch besser, wenn ihr einfach direkt eure Sachen so löst, weil wir können damit jetzt nichts anfangen. 16 Euro heißt es hier. Wir haben uns das Reddit auch anders vorgestellt, weil es sollte eher so darum gehen, so Podcast-fräzifische Themen. Ja, zum Connecten, irgendwie drüber reden oder sowas. Er schreibt hier so weirde Sachen. Wo entsorge ich leere Deodosen? Sind das Flaschen? Schreibt Benedikt. Nein. Benedikt. Aber ich weiss nicht, wo entsorgt man leere Deodosen? Müll. Welcher Müll? Alumüll. Alumüll. Okay, ich weiss, kann dir nichts mehr schreiben. Okay, Alumüll ist die Antwort. Okay, es sind keine Flaschen. Danke für euer Feedback. Ja, danke Leute. Vielen Dank fürs Feedback, haut rein und ansonsten wünschen wir euch weiter noch eine schöne Woche. Schönen Sommer. Schönen Sommer. Stellt euch in die Sonne, aufrecht, ganz aufrecht. Wir ziehen durch. Wir ziehen durch, wir machen keine Sommerpause. Nein. Es geht direkt weiter.
Das mag jetzt verwirrend klingen, weil wir gerade gesagt haben,
Florentin fährt ja weg. Ja, aber lass das unsere Sorge sein.
Ich fahre immer nur zwei Tage zwischen den Aufzeichnungen weg.
Genau. Und dann komme ich wieder zurück.
Lass das unsere Sorge sein, wir kriegen das hin.
Wir hören nicht auf, wir lassen euch nicht im Stich.
In diesen Zeiten lassen wir euch nicht im Stich.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das würden wir nicht tun.
Macht's gut, tschüss und wir heben.